comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc une surréaliste et hopitalisé il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les gros
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mercredi 15 décembre la
poursuite du désengagement militaire de
la france au mali après huit ans de
présence dans le pays l'armée française
qui tombouctou emmanuel macron se rendre
à bamako lundi pour y rencontrer le
président de la transition malienne une
visite dans un contexte diplomatique
tendu entre paris et bamako qui avait
accusé la france de l'avoir abandonnée
alors quel avenir pour le m'a dit
comment gérer désormais le risque
terroriste ou vos présents on retrouve à
notre reporter régis le sommier bamako
puis décryptage au plateau avec nos
invités
de les voir dans la rue en train de
manifester le monde de la justice est en
colère lançant des syndicats de
magistrats et greffiers ont appelé à la
grève aujourd'hui en france aux côtés
des avocats une mobilisation aussi les
digues que suivi de bordeaux à lyon à
rennes en passant par strasbourg ils ont
réclamé des moyens dignes pour la
justice un système judiciaire à bout de
souffle des professionnels épuisé nous
entendrons leurs revendications dans
cette émission
au sommaire à 21h la lutte contre le
kobe de 19 essais variant un nouveau
conseil de défense sanitaire aura lieu
vendredi en france pour évoquer
d'éventuelles restrictions
supplémentaires face à la flambée des
cas la vaccination des 5 11 ans ouverte
à partir d'aujourd'hui pour les enfants
à risque et depuis ce matin les français
plus de 65 ans ayant reçu une deuxième
dose doivent avoir fait leur rappelle
pour conserver leur pass annie terre
et alors on la campagne de vaccination
justement été d'argile agence européenne
des maladies affirme pourtant que le
vaccin ne suffira pas pour contrer la
propagation de omicron elle appelle à
prendre
des nouvelles restrictions et elle
appelle à la prudence accrue en cette
période de fêtes mais jusqu'où peuvent
aller ces restrictions qui prennent déjà
à la gorge de nombreux professionnels
dans notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français nous irons à la rencontre d'un
traître en région parisienne qui
aujourd'hui craint de devoir fermer
boutique définitivement un cri d'alarmé
à retrouver dès 21h
[Musique]
emmanuel macron attendu lundi à bamako
une visite dans le cadre du
désengagement militaire de la france au
mali après kidal était sa lite les
militaires de l'opération barkan donc
quitté hier la base de thon douteau
après huit années de présence les
précisions dans la capitale malienne de
régis le sommier grand reporter d'hergé
france
alors ici à bamako l'annnonce de la
visite du président français emmanuel
macron a surpris beaucoup de gens mais
ce n'est pas ce qui inquiète le plus les
maliens actuellement c'est précisément
le fait que la france la force barkan va
réduire de moitié d'ici six mois et la
perspective du départ des français
inquiètent la population pourquoi elle
inquiète parce que jusqu'à présent les
français avaient aidé on s'en souvient
en 2013 avec l'opération serval les
français avaient permis de stopper la
progression des colonnes djihadistes qui
venaient du nord et qui promettait à
l'époque d'envahir et de conquérir
bamako les français étaient à l'époque
vénéré on s'en souvient françois
hollande avait fait son discours à
tombouctou est précisément hier les
français se sont retirés de cette ville
cette ville symbole de cette victoire
d'autrefois alors cette rencontre entre
emmanuel macron la première rencontre
entre emmanuel macron et le président
assimilés aux états le colonel de la
jungle celui qui a fait les deux coups
d'état récemment au mali va permettre
peut-être de clarifier les choses en
effet les deux hommes ne se sont jamais
rencontrés se sont vu de nombreuses fois
au téléphone actuellement les maliens
ont le sentiment que la france certains
ont le sentiment que la france va les
abandonner et donc ils disent
naturellement nous nous tournons vers
d'autres et c'est le cas en particulier
de la société militaire privée wagner
russe c'est une perspective que les
français envisagent avec crainte
également espérons que cette rencontre
entre emmanuel macron et son homologue
malien permettent un certain nombre de
clarifications
ce départ de l'armée française de
tombouctou marque un tournant symbolique
en tout cas neuf ans plus tard le
million d'opérations barkan apparaît
mitigé
reportage donc ce retour plutôt sur les
principaux événements avec françois
xavier lambert
début 2012
dispersés dans l'immense étendue
désertique du sahel les groupes
jihadistes se renforce depuis la chute
du président libyen moammar kadhafi en
ont plutôt les terroristes menacent
directement les fragile gouvernement des
pays de la région et notamment le
pouvoir malien déboussolé après un coup
d'état mais il menace aussi les
nombreuses mines d'uranium exploitées
par le groupe français aura nos ex areva
profitant de la situation des centaines
de combattants lance une offensive en
décembre 2012 dans le nord du mali et
prennent le contrôle de plusieurs villes
alors que les djihadistes se dirige vers
bamako le gouvernement malien lance un
appel à l'aide à la france une demande à
laquelle répond immédiatement le
président français de l'époque le 11
janvier 2013 françois hollande annonce
le déclenchement de l'opération serval
les forces armées françaises ont apporté
cet après midi leur soutien aux unités
malienne pour lutter contre ces éléments
terroristes cette opération durera le
temps nécessaire j'informerai
régulièrement les français sur son
déroulement
rapidement les forces françaises
soutenues par les maliens reprennent le
contrôle de la situation
pour l'armée française c'est alors le
début de la traque des djihadistes en
ans plus tard en 2014 l'opération sert
val de vire l'opération barkan les pays
du sahel s'intègre dans ce nouveau
dispositif alors que les effectifs
français se renforce
ce sont 4500 soldats qui sont mobilisés
en 2018 l'action militaire accompagne
une action politique et diplomatique
forte et un projet de développement
technique économique et éducatif sur le
terrain sur cette lancée l'opération
barkan continue de recevoir des renforts
ont février 2020 les effectifs passent
de 4500 à 5200 militaires de nombreux
avions de chasse de l'infanterie des
drones sont également déployés pour
maintenir un semblant de stabilité dans
une zone où les djihadistes continue de
mener des attaques
mais la tâche est particulièrement
difficile et les morts se multiplient
dans les rangs français en novembre 2019
une collision entre hélicoptères
provoque la mort de treize militaires
j'assure du soutien du pays tout entier
les frères d'armes de nos treize morts
tous les autres poursuivent le combat au
sel
je redis à tous et à leur chef
ma confiance
malgré les difficultés la présence
française et des armes et du g5 ça elle
tient les djihadistes à distance cette
année le nombre d' attaques contre les
civils et au plus bas dans la région
depuis 2015 année de la signature
d'accords de paix entre bamako et
groupes rebelles du nord du pays face à
cette amélioration sécuritaire emmanuel
macron annonce en juin dernier la fin de
l'opération barkan sous sa forme
actuelle trois mille soldats français
devraient rester déployés dans la région
pour épauler les forces régionales en
neuf ans la france a perdu 52 soldats
dans le sahel
alors visite surprise des manuels mac
rôle m'a dit lundi prochain alors que la
france a décidé de quitter plusieurs
bases militaires du nord du pays avec ce
départ progressif de l'opération barkan
faut-il craindre une détérioration de la
situation sécuritaire pensez vous comme
le premier ministre malien que la france
abandonne bamako en étant toujours vos
réactions sur notre compte télégramme
d'ayrté france et place maintenant un
autre face à face
[Musique]
avec nour pour en parler le général
françois chaumont six experts en
géostratégie
bonsoir général merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés bakary traoré journée lés
spécialistes du mali et du sahel bonsoir
à vous aussi merci d'être là vous êtes
bakary traoré en direct de bamako donc
visite surprise dans des manuels macro
lundi prochain dans le pays c'est une
visite nécessaire général show
devanciers alors que les relations entre
paris et bamako sont tendues il y à des
mises au point à faire
oui sans aucun doute y'a des mises au
point à faire je pense qu'aujourd'hui de
toute façon la france a décidé de
resserrer son dispositif de cette une ce
n'est pas une nouvelle ça fait plusieurs
mois que ça a été évoqué il ya deux
raisons à ça la première est
effectivement il ya des tensions avec le
gouvernement malien sans aucun doute
ensuite vous avez évoqué dans votre
reportage le groupe wagner je crois que
le président mac ont été très clairs sur
la question il peut pas y avoir
cohabitation avec le groupe wagner et
puis maintenant il faut reconnaître le
gouvernement malien a toute sa
responsabilité
pour gérer la crise sur son territoire
il est souverain c'est à lui de faire
ses choix
justement qu'il va demander aux
autorités clairement malienne de se
positionner sur la présence de ce groupe
paramilitaire russe selon nos confrères
de rfi il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
l'union européenne a suspendu
temporairement sa mission de formation
des forces armées centrafricaines ont
raison selon de ce contrôle exercé selon
eux par wagner c'est vraiment la ligne
rouge
bakary traoré comme le disait d'ailleurs
il ya quelques semaines jean yves le
drian
oui j'ai selon jean yves le drian bien
sûr que c'est une ligne rouge cette
coopération éventuelle dans le futur
avec deux avec la société privée l'usso
wagner mais du côté du gouvernement d'où
le terme indien il est toujours question
carrie traoré qu'on a récupéré ou pas
non voilà n'ont pas pas encore
manifestement effectivement général
chavancy il n'y aura cette mise au point
nécessaire jean yves le drian il l'avait
dit il ya quelques semaines ce n'est pas
compatible avec la mission des des
européens clairement il va falloir pour
les autorités maliennes choisir entre
ces deux options
à vous tout à fait sans aucun doute la
ligne rouge pour nous elle est très
claire il peut pas y avoir cohabitation
le groupe wagner n'a quand même pas une
très grande
une réputation très positive ne
l'oublions pas quand même il est accusé
d'un certain nombre de méfaits dans
d'autres pays dont la centrafrique et
donc on ne peut pas se retrouver dans un
contexte comme le mali avec une force
privé de mercenaires avec une force
régaliennes comme celle de la france qui
vient aider le mali il faut faire un
choix sans aucun doute alors on va
écouter le premier ministre malien qui
avait justement fin septembre critiqué
la france en devant l'onu après la
décision de de paris de retirer ses
forces de l'opération barkan son propose
de l'écouter
du mali règle est que le principe de
consultation et de concertation qui doit
être la règle entre partenaires
privilégiés n'est pas été observé en
amant de la décision du gouvernement
phrase la nouvelle situation née de la
fin de barkan place à le mali devant le
fait accompli et l'exposent à 1,7 à une
espèce d'abandon en plein vol nous
conduit à explorer les voies et moyens
pour mieux assurer la sécurité
d'une manière autonome avec d'autres
partenaires le premier ministre voit se
justifie sur ses autres vous a dit il
pour mieux assurer la sécurité il parle
d'abandon
justement choguel
kokalla c'est le sentiment vous avez
aussi et bakary traoré ce qu'on peut
réellement parler aujourd'hui d'abandon
en tout cas c'est ce que ressentent de
de nombreux maliens oui tout à fait
alors je sais pas si vous me laissez si
on vous entend
on vous entend bakary traoré
voilà décidément effectivement ben
justement je vous propose d'aller à
défaut d'entendre la réponse de bakary
traoré d'entendre la voix de certains
maliens interrogé dans dans les rues de
bamako aujourd'hui certains évidemment
se disent inquiets mais surtout déçu par
ce départ
en huit ans de présence au mali la jeune
française n'a rien foutu il faut le dire
je dirais une des séries des parts de la
nation malienne une décennie
complètement perdus comme ça
c'est un bilan catastrophique si nantes
car l'armée française venait vous avez
l'entousiasme là que des maliens partout
un peu partout à bamako à tombouctou un
peu partout de la même façon si
l'armateur français décident de partir
ou de se réorganiser ou du moins de
quitter un point a vers un point b la
population devait ressentir encore pour
les féliciter verra ce que vous avez vu
ça non on est déçu quand la france dit
qu'ils gagnent les balles la base peut
aller de l'autre côté de moi je vois que
ce sont des des choses pour pouvoir
écouter conquérir le pouvoir malien
c'est archi faux achim va pas se laisser
faire et le peuple malien si c'est pas
un crime c'est le peuple malien va
passer les effets général françois
chavance y est ça vous étonne cette
réaction aujourd'hui
de certains habitants malien c'est une
forme d'ingratitude selon vous
tout simplement voilà de la déception
légitime
il ya une déception des maliens mais je
crois que la première question que les
maliens que nous venons d'entendre
devrait se poser est la suivante est-ce
que l'armée malienne a fait tout le
travail en huit ans qu'on attendait de
l'armée de son pays aujourd'hui les
résultats de l'armée malienne commence
un petit peu à s'améliorer grâce à
l'aide des français car ce n'est pas des
français qui doivent se battre pour les
maliens mais les maliens qui doivent se
battre pour les maliens et que les
reportages des interviews à diffuser la
montre bien qu une totale
incompréhension
nous avons des citoyens magnin qui
attendent qu'un état étranger la france
viennent faire le travail qui devrait
faire eux mêmes donc je trouve c'est
assez injuste maintenant on peut
comprendre que le sentiment d'insécurité
puisse exister mais il faut pas médecin
sur dawn armées françaises l'armée
française a eu de très bons résultats en
éliminant les chefs djihadistes c'est la
première mission nous avons ce n'est pas
de restaurer la sécurité qui est de la
responsabilité de l'état malien qui est
totalement responsable de cette
situation et c'est très facile
aujourd'hui d'accuser la france de ne
pas avoir fait le travail la france paye
les opérations elles payent de la vie de
ses soldats et elle le fait depuis huit
ans sans rien demander en échange
effectivement il y a un peu
d'ingratitude
justement voici
venir celui de france les français ont
perdu la vie au mali pour quel résultat
un abandon point d'interrogation il
était peut-être le temps de partir c'est
vrai que je parle sous votre contrôle 53
morts de soldats français au mali
tons sable pour sa soirée et ont tenté
de dire aujourd'hui françois français
n'auront pas du tout je n'oublions pas
quand même que nous avons une armée
professionnelle une armée de soldats qui
répondent aux besoins de notre chef des
armées et que notre métier c'est de
faire la guerre donc tout le nous la
faisons il y à des pertes cela arrive
c'est malheureux mais il n'y a pas de
guerre sans perte je crois que se
focaliser sur le nombre de soldats
français tués en opération en huit ans
n'a pas beaucoup de sens en géopolitique
il a un sens au point de vue humain mais
pas au point de vue géopolitique
maintenant il est certain mais comme
dans toute guerre de ce type c'est une
guerre de contre-insurrection des
groupes terroristes qui sont diluées
dans le paysage sur dix fois la taille
de la france on ne peut pas vaincre
cesser ses mouvements on ne peut que les
réduire à l'impuissance autant que
possible la solution sera politique
d'ailleurs le président macron l'a dit
il faut une situation politique encore
faut-il que ça ce qui est ce dialogue
entre le gouvernement malien et s'ébroue
à condition qu'ils abandonnent leurs
actions terroristes
or ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui que
sont des assassins sous un motif
politique ne l'oublions pas général
françois chavancy désormais c'est la
jeune femme européenne takouba qui va
assurer la transition notamment dans
dans la zone des trois frontières on
descend peut-être davantage un petit peu
plus le nord du pays on le voit les
habitants sont inquiets de cette
résurgence de terrorisme parce qu'ils
ont raison de l'être
tout à fait c'est une zone qui était
privilégiée par les groupes terroristes
islamistes ne l'oublions pas il y avait
leur base donc en plus c'est une zone
très facile pour ces mouvements dans la
mesure où c'est un ya trois frontières
vous avez le niger le burkina et le mali
donc d une zone sont à lire difficile à
contrôler et je dirais que politiquement
donc l'effort est porté depuis plusieurs
mois sinon plusieurs années sur ce
triangle pour justement rassurer les
populations et bien sûr détruire
l'ennemi donc oui
les les habitants ont besoin de cette
aide et c'est ce que nous procurons
aujourd'hui les forces françaises ne se
retire pas du mali à date d'aujourd'hui
elle se réorganise avec moins
d'effectifs peut-être et elles
concentrent leurs efforts sur l'ennemi
dans une mission de destruction qui est
un peu différente et à kouba va le
permettre puis ce sont des forces
spéciales dont de plusieurs pays
européens environ 900 hommes je crois
donc effectivement ça va être plutôt
efficace pour la chasse aux terroristes
c'est beaucoup en général françois
chavance i merci à bakary traoré
malheureusement cette saison n'a pas
permis de deux d'exécuter 2 le face à
face que nous souhaitions faire l'enfant
en tout cas on a eu des clés de lecture
merci à vous d'avoir été en direct avec
mon ce soir
et dans le reste de l'actualité en
afrique la tunisie qui s'enfonce dans la
crise économique et politique pour
rembourser sa dette le président fait
appel à l'aide de son voisin l'algérie
300 millions de dollars débloqué
aujourd'hui par le président algérien
c'était lors d'une visite d'état de deux
jours à tunis les détails avec notre
correspondant sur place basse m shelly
abdelmadjid tabouna tunis deux ans après
son accession au pouvoir une première
visite officielle du chef de l'état
algérien qui s'inscrit dans la poursuite
des travaux de coopération entre tunis
et alger signe des liens qui unissent
les deux pays l'algérie avait été
choisie comme première sortie officielle
du président sayyed à l'issue de son
élection en 2019 a tunis les 15 et 16
décembre le président tebboune a annoncé
que cette visite sera l'occasion de
consolider les relations bilatérales
entre les deux voisins en revenant
notamment sur la lutte antiterroriste le
développement des régions frontalières
le dossier libyen ou encore celui du sel
l'intégration économique en afrique du
nord ou encore l'aide à la tunisie pour
l'accompagner dans sa sortie de crise
écouter
cette visite s'inscrit dans le cadre du
renforcement des liens de fraternité
entre les deux peuples frères il est
question également d'élargir les
domaines de coopération à un niveau
qualitatif sur des questions régionales
et internationales d'actualité et de
concrétiser la volonté commune des
dirigeants des deux pays et de leurs
peuples
confronté à une crise économique et
politique sans précédent la tunisie
trouve de plus en plus de difficultés à
mobiliser les ressources financières
nécessaires pour boucler son budget 2021
après la dégradation de sa note
souveraine et l'échec des négociations
avec le fmi et le refus de prêt des
émirats ou encore de l'arabie saoudite
c'est auprès du voisin algérien que
tunis a pu trouver de l'aide en marge de
cette visite d'état un protocole
financier avait été conclu le 9 décembre
dernier entre la tunisie et l'agérie
portant sur l'octroi d'un prêt de 300
millions de dollars au profit de la
république tunisienne une aide
inattendue qui permettra peut-être à la
tunisie de limiter les dégâts dans un
pays au bord de l'implosion économique
et social
à quatre mois de la présidentielle à
certains candidats font de l'outre-mer
un dossier crucial jean luc mélenchon
lui ni d'heure de la france insoumise et
en guadeloupe marine le pen 1 du
rassemblement national les quand tu es
la meilleure thibault janin
une conférence de presse avant de
s'envoler pour l'océan indien la
candidate du rassemblement national a
choisi de se rendre à mayotte pour
démarrer sa campagne auprès des
ultramarins presque mayotte est un
symbole c'est un symbole de ce que nous
pourrions vivre demain si on ne fait
rien et c'est un symbole aussi de
l'abandon de l'état à l'égard d'un de
ses départements l'abandon total
les mots sont forts et c'est sur ce
constat que marine le pen s'est envolé
ce mercredi à destination de mamoudzou
durement touché par la crise sanitaire
lille fait également face à une forte
immigration clandestine en provenance
des comores et à une insécurité
grandissante
de thèmes sur lesquels la candidate du
rassemblement national compte s'appuyer
lors de sa visite sur place avant de
rejoindre la réunion autres territoires
français d'outre-mer où fabien roussel
est lui aussi attendu du 16 au 21
décembre
pour le candidat communiste à la
présidentielle
ce sera notamment l'occasion de
détailler son plan d'urgence pour les
autres maires lors d'un meeting prévu
vendredi à sainte suzanne ne pas
négliger les régions d'outremer c'est
également la stratégie adoptée par jean
luc mélenchon le candidat de la france
insoumise a décidé de se rendre de
l'autre côté du globe aux antilles avec
pour première destination la guadeloupe
où il a atterri mardi après midi depuis
pointe-à-pitre le candidat de la france
un soumises s'est montré très critique
vis-à-vis du gouvernement sur sa gestion
de la crise sociale et sanitaire qui a
frappé l'île ces dernières semaines
quand on dit ce qui se passe en
guadeloupe le plus souvent ne nous
croient pas ce n'est pas supportable ce
n'est pas acceptable notre pays devrait
avoir honte de traité de telle manière
toute une partie de sa population
jean luc mélenchon poursuivra sa
campagne sous les alizés en martinique
autres régions marquées par de fortes
contestations face à l'obligation
vaccinale des soignants notamment
l'opération séduction en outre mer est
donc lancé la période est d'autant plus
propice que l'exécutif a bien du mal à
convaincre la visite express de
sébastien lecornu en martinique et en
guadeloupe en pleine crise sociale a
fortement déçu sur place tout comme la
gestion du troisième référendum sur
l'indépendance en nouvelle calédonie en
2017 c'est d'ailleurs en outre-mer que
les candidats marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon ont réalisé leurs meilleurs
scores nationaux lors de la
présidentielle
on est toujours en france avec se fait
plutôt rare le monde la justice dans la
rue magistrats greffiers et avocats se
sont rassemblés dans plusieurs villes
pour dénoncer une justice malade une
mobilisation générale à l'appel de 17
organisations syndicales ont fait le
point sur leurs revendications avec
emilie goog h
rendre la justice mais avec des moyens
dignes c'est ce que demandent tout un
corps de métier à bout face à la
difficulté des conditions de travail
devant le ministère de l'économie et des
finances à paris plusieurs centaines de
magistrats avocats et greffiers ont
dénoncé les obstacles auxquels ils font
face au quotidien et qui nuisent au bon
déroulement de la justice
quand vous attendez 18 mois pour
divorcer trois ans pour voir juger votre
licenciement ou 18 mois pour voir juger
votre agresseur ça a des répercussions
sur les gens et donc ce que nous
renvoient aussi les justiciables c'est à
dire on comprend plus c'est trop lent il
se passe rien ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on comprend en pleine figure que mes
collègues prennent en pleine figure des
gens ils viennent vers la justice pour
toi des solutions pour que leur litige
soit réglé rapidement efficacement et on
se retrouve avec des procédures qui se
termine des années après et où la peine
en tout cas en matière pénale est
prononcée
des années après n'a plus aucun sens au
moment où elle est prononcée autre
manifestation à lyon au tribunal
judiciaire ils sont des centaines à
s'être joint à cet appel national auquel
participent l'ensemble des
professionnels du secteur un faits
décrits comme rarissime par une avocate
alors c'est un jour vraiment historique
parce que sur l'ensemble de la france
les magistrats du siège c'est à dire les
magistrats des tribunaux ordinaires les
magistrats du parquet c'est-à-dire qu'il
représente le procureur de la république
donc le ministre de la justice les
greffiers et les avocats se joignent
tous ensemble ce qui est rarissime avec
cette mobilisation certains espèrent que
les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle saisirons le problème à
bras le corps car ils décrivent un
manque de moyens indignes d'un état de
droit on attend un recrutement massif de
magistrats et de graff et pas que des
sucres rapides comme l'a dit que notre
carnation on attend des locaux on attend
des moyens informatiques
on attend également
à une cessation des réformes qui
s'empilent ans qu'on est plus en mesure
d'absorber il ya une question taboue
mais moyens de la justice c'est ça que
magistrats avocats et greffiers sont
venus dire aujourd'hui l'hypocrisie êtes
chichis la justice est à bout de souffle
et donc il faut maintenant prendre le
taureau par les cornes les magistrats
sortent pour la première fois de leur
devoir de réserve et cela montre la
gravité de la situation la justice qui
est rendue aujourd'hui mais plus à la
hauteur d'un état de droit cette journée
de mobilisation nationale arrive trois
semaines après la publication d'une
tribune signée presque à l'unanimité par
les professionnels de la justice elle
dénonce là aussi leur malaise et la
perte de sens ressenti dans leur métier
ce mercredi matin avant le début de la
mobilisation
eric dupond-moretti déclaré les avoir
écoutés et entendus ou suivre mon action
au service de la justice le ministre de
la justice a assuré avoir réparé l'ue
rejoint l'opposition péremptoire et pour
aller plus loin annonçant son ce bateau
avec caroline mécary avocate également
membre du conseil national des barreaux
bonsoir caroline mécary merci d'être
avec nous c'est pas vraiment fréquent de
voir le monde la justice dans son
ensemble dans la rue comme ça des juges
avec des ados c'est du jamais vu y voit
la c4 imedi c'est du jamais vu notamment
ça a démarré avec la tribune qui a été
signé le 23 novembre par plus de 3000
magistrats professionnels aujourd'hui il
y à 7700 personnels de justice
magistrats et greffiers qui l'ont signé
je rappelle qu'en france il ya neuf
mille magistrats professionnels et que
donc c'est inédit la cour de cassation
aussi a pris position leem syndicat de
magistrats du système administratif au
sont aussi venus au soutien les avocats
tout le monde tout le monde des robes
n'en peut plus en réalité nous sommes au
bord du burn out réellement quand on
vous dit qu'on manque de moyens humains
et matériels c'est une réalité et ce à
une répercussion sur les justiciables
pourquoi est ce qu'on met trois ans pour
avoir un jugement devant le conseil des
prud'hommes n'y a pas assez de juges
pour juger on va évidemment parler renée
mais non pour l'argent c'est très
intéressant vous avez raison d'être
passionnés parce que l'heure est grave
semble-t-il mais la question qu'on se
pose pourquoi maintenant et pourquoi est
ce pire maintenant est-ce que ça l'est
on s'est juste un ras-le-bol de
plusieurs années de ou saas ou
finalement est-ce que ça s'est aggravé
là alors en fait j'ai il ya il ya un
pardon de le dire comme ça il ya une
goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase
qui est le suicide d'une jeune m'a dit
magistrate de 29 ans au mois d'août 2021
dans le nord de la france était une juge
placé c'est à dire une juge qui
remplaçait les jugements quand les juges
malade et elle s'est retrouvée dans une
situation personnelle au regard du
travail qui était le sien qui l'a
conduit à se suicider et ça a fait un
tel écho parce qu'en réalité la
souffrance au travail des magistrats
c'est quelque chose qui était
diagnostiquée notamment par le syndicat
de la magistrature dans un rapport qui a
été rendu il ya deux ans donc on est
arrivé à un point de rupture voilà c'est
ça on est au bord de l'implosion et vous
avez raison ça ne marche pas ça ne
marche pas que maintenant c'est à dire
que c'est aussi le résultat d'un abandon
de l'institution judiciaire au moins
depuis nicolas sarkozy au moins une
rachida dati qui n'a strictement rien
fait qu'est ce qu'elle a fait elle a
supprimé des juridictions de proximité
c'est à dire qu'elle a réduit l'accès
aux justices de la justice aux
justiciables et ça a continué comme ça
avec austin christiane taubira en
réalité et christiane taubira elle a eu
un magistère de la parole mais elle n'a
rien fait pour le fonctionnement de
l'institution judiciaire réellement
celui qui a essayé de faire quelque
chose ce n'est pas tout dire à ces
monsieurs urvoas qui l'a qui lui a
succédé et qui lui a vraiment tiré la
sonnette la sonnette d'alarmé en
essayant d'obtenir de bercy des moyens
supplémentaires souvenez vous c'est lui
qui dit la justice est en voie de
clochardisation
on est en 2016 ok monsieur macron est
élu qu'est ce qui est fait depuis que
monsieur macron était lui quasiment rien
et donc les problèmes s'accumulent le
retard s'accumule nous ce que nous
disons trek très très clairement avec
les magistrats c'est que en effet il
faut doubler le nombre de magistrats
professionnels
on en a neuf mille aujourd'hui je
rappelle qu'en 1920 il y en avait huit
mille pour une population cadre de deux
français qu'à doubler voilà les
greffiers il faut les doubler ce n'est
plus possible
sans ces personnels humains compétents
formés l'institution judiciaire ne peut
pas fonctionner donc alors eric dupond
moretti lui il n'est pas tellement
d'accord avec vous parce qu'il dit mais
moi j'ai réparé l'urgence il a défendu
son son bilan humain de jetair gabriela
talent qui vient on soutient le porte
parole du gouvernement qui dit qu'il y
aurait une augmentation 30 % du budget
de la justice alors qu'est-ce que vérité
fondée mais très simplement que
l'augmentation du budget de la justice
qui est une réalité en effet de 8 % à 30
% 30 % sur les cinq ans mais les 8%
cette année et sur les quatre ans
précédant quasiment quatre ans
précédents ça a été consacrée
essentiellement à l'administration
pénitentiaire pas au fonctionnement des
tribunaux
c'est à dire ces lieux où les citoyens
peuvent trouver le moyen de faire régler
leurs différends par un tiers qui est le
juge et ça c'est un facteur de paix
sociale tant que un ministre comme
monsieur dupont moretti qui ce matin sur
france inter véritablement a été minable
en essayant de reporter la faute à la
fois sur la grève des avocats sur le
fait de ses prédécesseurs pourtant qu'à
lui-même oui mais juste mais peu importe
en fait vous savez monsieur dupont
moretti aujourd'hui il est il a changé
de clients sont gagnants c'est monsieur
macron donc il soutient tout ce que dit
monsieur macron avant ils soutenaient
les criminels ce qui est tout à son
honneur aujourd'hui et soutient un homme
politique et il a cessé de porter la
robe est il assez c'est vraiment de
porter la robe il a endossé le costume
du ministre 2 du président macro qui n'a
aucun intérêt pour l'institution
judiciaire absolument aucun et pourquoi
tout simplement parce que lui comme sans
doute ses prédécesseurs ne veut pas que
l'institution judiciaire puisse avoir du
pouvoir nous ce qu'on demande aux gens
de robe nous qui aimons notre métier
nous aimons notre métier nous aimons
défendre les gens et les juges m jugez
les justiciables mais ils veulent le
faire dans de bonnes conditions
si le juge ne peut pas juger dans de
bonnes conditions ça va se reporter
évidemment sur le justiciable au premier
chef tout le monde paye paye les paye
les pots cassés donc là il y à vraiment
la sonnette d'alarmé qui est plus que
tiré parce que nous sommes au bord de
l'implosion nous sommes au bord du burn
out nous avons des solutions pour
améliorer le fonctionnement de la
justice y compris dans son management
comme l'a indiqué monsieur dupont
moretti nous les connaissons les sujets
c'est pas ça ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
et les états généraux de la justice là
qui sont mis en place
de la communication il se moque vraiment
du monde c'est de la poudre de
perlimpinpin franchement ils nous
prennent pour des quetsches on a les
solutions des gros atelier sur la
justice on les a on a on a travaillé on
sait ce qu'il faut faire nous avons
besoin d'avoir plus de juge que ceux de
greffiers nous avons besoin d'avoir la
fin de ces réformes sempiternelle qui
n'ont qu'un seul objet faire en sorte
que le justiciable sortent du circuit
judiciaire nous avons besoin d'avoir la
suppression du décret magin dit par
exemple sur les procédures d'appel
augmentation des places aux concours de
la magistrature et bien ça a été intense
mais mais mais mais ça doit être fait de
manier de manière beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus ample il faut ouvrir beaucoup plus
il faut faire des concours spéciaux
voilà et non pas uniquement recruter des
contractuels qui sont certes peuvent
être utiles peuvent aider mais ce ne
sont pas des magistrats ou ce ne sont
pas des greffiers or il ya un lien dans
la fonction de magistrat ou dans la
fonction de greffier il y a une garantie
qui est donnée à la fois à la république
et aux justiciables dans l'exercice du
métier et puis des contractuels c'est
des gens que vous pouvez mettre dehors
au bout de un an deux ans trois ans si
ça vous plait pas alors des
fonctionnaires comme les magistrats ou
les greffiers vous ne pouvez pas les
mettre dehors aujourd'hui vous demande
d'être reçus par bruno le maire il ya eu
une réunion ce soir pas par bruno le
maire un directeur de cabinet ça risque
quelconque je sais plus lequel
d'ailleurs elle 19 heures et en effet il
ya une il y a eu un rendez vous je n'ai
pas eu de retour de ce rendez vous mais
ça montre vraiment le peu de
considération que qui est donnée par ce
gouvernement à l'institution judiciaire
quand on a une mobilisation de l'ampleur
de celle que nous à laquelle nous
assistons aujourd'hui qui a été je veux
dire quand vous venez d y aller elle est
à la fois inédit les lits en fin et que
la réponse est d'être qu'ont reçus par
un conseiller du cabinet blablabli et
blablabla c'est que véritablement on se
demande quel est le projet de monsieur
macro pour la justice donc je vous avais
en elle et bruno le maire est pas ému
tout simplement parce que qui en fait
aujourd'hui
tiens j'allais dire les ficelles en tout
cas celui qui tient les cordons de la
bourse et bruno le maire ce n'est pas
monsieur nombreux moretti monsieur
dupont moretti ce même son cabinet il ne
l'a pas choisi et donc il a été
incapable de prendre ne serait-ce qu'un
magistrat qui soit en mesure de discuter
avec l'administration de bercy comme
l'avait fait par exemple jean jacques
urvoas qui avait eu l'intelligence de
recruter un haut fonctionnaire qui était
passé par bercy avant de l'intégrer dans
son cabinet donc voilà monsieur dupont
moretti c'est en réalité un
j'allais dire un enfin peu importe ce
que monsieur dupont moretti nous nous
sommes adressés à celui qui pouvait nous
donner satisfaction d'une manière ou
d'une autre et pas à celui au fond qui
n'est qu'une marionnette qui ne fait que
représenter son client monsieur macron
aujourd'hui quand vous voyez les
candidats à la présidentielle alors je
ne manque pas ici d'en promouvoir l'un
ou l'autre mais enfin est-ce que ça
laisse tout de même de l'espoir est ce
que cette souffrance de la justice est
prise en compte d'une manière générale
par les candidats à la présidentielle on
se parle pardonnez moi d'abord pour le
moment que je sauf erreur de ma part
madame pécresse monsieur zemmour badham
le pen pour la droite de ce que j'en
sais n'ont pas de programme ou se basent
ces belles affiches à gauche le seul qui
a un programme c'est monsieur jean luc
mélenchon bien un programme pour la
justice moi je pense qu'il doit est ce
programme-là doit impérativement être
musclé et c'est peut être l'opportunité
pour les candidats à la présidentielle
qui ne cesse de nous parler de sécurité
et de police qu'ils s'intéressent enfin
une bonne fois pour toutes à
l'institution judiciaire qui est quand
même un élément essentiel dans un état
de droit démocratique
il n'y a pas de démocratie sans justice
ça n'est pas possible donc j'attends
aussi en tout cas c'est mon souhait est
que ces candidats à la présidentielle
travail leurs programmes sur la question
deux pour répondre à la demande qui est
la demande certes des professionnels
mais nous ne nous ne le faisons pas pour
nous nous le faisons pour les citoyens
pour les justiciables c'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que nous ne sommes
pas dans une démarche corporatiste nous
ne demandons pas d'argent pour nous nous
ne demandons pas d'augmentation de
salaire non nous demandons des moyens
humains c'est-à-dire des femmes et des
hommes qui soit capable d'écouter les
procès qui soit capable de rendre des
jugements dans des délais déraisonnables
qui nous disent pas à une dame qui vient
pour une pension alimentaire bonjour
madame vous revenez dans un an ou qui ne
disent pas une jeune fille qui a été
violée en 2016 à bas la cour d'assises
traître à votre dossier en 2023 par
exemple ou qui mettent pas 3 3e rang à
rendre un jugement devant le conseil des
prud'hommes on a le sentiment que ce que
vous nous dites les hôpitaux le monde de
la santé dit la même chose c'est tout
simplement aujourd'hui une défaillance
majeure des services publics un abandon
laisse alors oui je suis d'accord
effectivement on peut faire un parallèle
dans ce qui se passe pour tous les
services publics que ce soit le service
public de la police que ce soit le
service public de la santé ou celui de
l'éducation on a on assiste exactement à
la même chose dans pour le service
public de 2 de la justice et là on voit
bien qu'en réalité ça correspond à des
logiques à des choix politiques qui ont
été faits depuis effectivement ça ne
date pas de monsieur macro mais macron
les à amplifier mais ce sont des choix
politiques qui sont faits de détricoter
ce qui a été mis en place par le conseil
national de la résistance après la
deuxième guerre mondiale donc d'offrir
des services publics à tous les citoyens
service public dont on est bien content
qu'on l'ait bien content d'avoir quand
même donc nous nous battons en effet
pour le maintien du service public de la
justice et nous espérons que en tout cas
nous souhaitons être entendu merci
beaucoup car les magazines en tout cas
on a entendu ce soir merci à vous
dans le reste de l'actualité cette
explosion d'un camion citerne en haïti
on compte au moins 75 morts et 48
blessés une quarantaine d'habitations
ont été ravagés par les flammes à
nouveau drame dans un pays déjà marqué
par les catastrophes naturelles la
pauvreté endémique et l'instabilité
politique chronique juliette lamy
c'est une tragédie de plus pour le pays
cap haïtien pleure la mort de dizaines
de personnes dans l'explosion d'un
camion citerne
le camion se serait retourné en tentant
d'éviter une motocyclette des passants
se serait alors précipités pour
récupérer de l'essence un carburant rare
dans le pays mais le véhicule a
rapidement exploser le premier ministre
par intérim
ariel henry a annoncé que des hôpitaux
de campagne avait été déployé pour
prendre en charge les blessés et il a
également décrété trois jours de deuil
national
après le drame le gouvernement et les
pouvoirs publics ont été mobilisés des
fonds d'urgence ont été débloqués des
mesures seront par ailleurs prises pour
l'organisation des funérailles
nationales en faveur des victimes ce
terrible accident intervient alors que
le pays fait face à une forte pénurie de
carburants la hausse des prix de
l'essence avait d'ailleurs suscité des
manifestations lundi dernier depuis
plusieurs mois des bandes armées
contrôlent les axes routiers qui
conduisent aux terminaux pétroliers
depuis octobre les réseaux de
télécommunications et les médias ne
fonctionne que très peu car les
générateurs qui alimente les antennes
ont besoin de carburant une crise
énergétique qui handicape également les
rares structures hospitalières du pays
ce mardi le premier ministre par intérim
s'est rendu sur les lieux du drame et a
apporté son soutien aux blessés à la
tête d'une importante délégation je suis
actuellement au cap où j'ai pu constater
l'ampleur des dégâts à l'hôpital
justinien où je visite les blessés c'est
avec le coeur déchiré que je constate
l'état critique de certains de nos
compatriotes admis à cet établissement
la gestion de cette tragédie et d'autant
plus difficile que l'état est confronté
à une forte crise humanitaire haïti pays
le plus pauvre d'amérique latine et des
caraïbes doit aussi faire face à
l'instabilité politique depuis le
meurtre de l'ancien président juvénal
moïse ariel henry fait office de chef
d'état mais le chef par intérim du
gouvernement est loin de faire
l'unanimité sur l'ensemble du territoire
haïtien
et direction à présent les états unis où
l'assaut du capitole revient sur le
devant de la scène le dernier chef de
cabinet de donald trump pourrait être
poursuivi pour son refus de coopérer l
enquête sur les émeutes du 6 janvier on
retrouve à washington notre
correspondant thomas bonnet bonsoir coma
l'étau se resserre donc un peu plus sur
l'ancien président américain donald
trump
oui parce que marc meadows parce que
c'est de lui dont il est question est
donc l'ancien chef de cabinet de donald
trump c'est un très proche de l'ancien
président et il a donc refusé de
témoigner devant cette commission d'
enquête parlementaire chargée d'enquêter
sur les événements du 6 janvier dernier
au capitole il a quand même coopérer
avec cette commission puisqu'il a livré
des milliers de documents notamment des
sms qui n'avait reçu ce jour là mais il
a en revanche décidé d'en garder à
certains autres qu'ils jugent comme
confidentielles et comme étant protégée
par un dispositif qu'on appelle ici le
privilège exécutif et c'est d'ailleurs
tout le débat de savoir si les
communications présidentielle peuvent
être protégés par le privilège exécutif
au vu de la gravité des faits qui se
sont produits le 6 janvier au capitole
alors en tout cas marc meadows devient
le premier ancien parlementaire à être
visé par des poursuites pénales par le
congrès américain une décision approuvée
par joe biden qui a été interrogé à ce
sujet par des journalistes et il a
estimé que marc meadows méritée selon
lui d'être poursuivi pour son entrave
aux travaux de cette commission denquête
on peut dire en tout cas que la décision
elle est dit 10 au sein des
parlementaires américains écouter ses
réactions
il est regrettable que nous soyons de
retour dans cette enceinte pour examiner
une nouvelle recommandation aux
poursuites criminelles mais notre ancien
collègue monsieur me doses ne nous
laisse pas le choix
j'espère que le peuple américain est
très attentif à ce qui se passe j'espère
qu'ils voient ce qui se passe quand les
démocrates obtiennent un pouvoir total
ils en abusent ils intimident il menace
et il harcèle et il tente de mettre
leurs opposants politiques en prison
ensher ce sera maintenant aux procureurs
fédéraux de décider s'ils inculpent ou
non marc meadows pour sa non coopération
c'est la décision en tout cas qu'ils
avaient été prises pour à peu près les
mêmes motifs en ce qui concerne un autre
conseiller de donald trump steve banane
dont le procès se tiendra l'été prochain
il est intéressant de noter aussi que
marc meadows lui même a déposé plainte
contre cette commission d' enquête
estimant que ces assignations à
comparaître était démesurée on rappelle
que cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire est composée
principalement de démocrates et de deux
républicains qui ont pris leurs
distances avec donald trump la volonté
visiblement et d'aller très vite dans
les travaux menés par cette commission
notamment pour arriver avant les
élections de mi-mandat qui vont se tenir
vous le savez à l'automne prochain ici
aux etats-unis et la question centrale
de cette enquête c'est de savoir quel
était le rôle de donald trump dans les
agissements violents qui ont eu lieu le
6 janvier au capital on est prêt
maintenant d'un an après des ajustements
ces événements au capitole et on peut
voir donc que les débats sont toujours
animées autour de cette question c'est
d'ailleurs ce que reproche donald trump
utiliser cette enquête pour occuper
l'espace médiatique avec à ces images du
6 janvier dernier au capitole dans ce
que lui considère comme une chasse aux
sorcières merci thomas bonnin en direct
de washington et les etats-unis qui
accusent toujours l'iran de vouloir
gagner du temps pour se doter de l'armé
nucléaire résultat toujours pas
d'entente pour relancer l'accord signé à
vienne en 2015 après deux semaines de
négociations de son côté téhéran demande
la levée des sanctions économiques
farah mais qui
des négociations décevantes aux yeux de
plusieurs diplomates à vienne les
discussions entre les trois signataires
européens d'une part à savoir la france
l'allemagne et la grande bretagne et les
iraniens d'autre part s'enlise entre
pressions occidentales et méfiance
iranienne les pourparlers concernant le
retour de l'iran dans les accords de
vienne sont au point mort
nos négociations avec monsieur raphaël
grossi porté sur les revendications sûr
car âge
les négociations sont toujours en cours
et n'ont pas encore abouti
il est toujours sous l'influencé de
considérations politiques et
d'opérations psychologique de pression
[Musique]
lusine de carrache produit des
centrifugeuses et ne fait pas partie des
sites nucléaires déclaré mais depuis une
explosion survenue en début d'année
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique insiste pour le visiter les
iraniens font de la levée totale des
sanctions internationales qui étrangle
leurs économies depuis 2018 une
condition préalable à toute avancée
cette exigence est jugé inacceptable et
rejetée par washington il sera bientôt
trop tard l'iran n'est toujours pas
engagé dans de vraies négociations
ce que nous voyons jusqu'ici c'est que
l'iran perd un temps précieux en
défendant des positions qui sont
incompatibles avec un retour dans
l'accord de vienne de 2015 depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir de
l'ultraconservateur ebrahim raïssi en
juin dernier
les relations entre l'iran et les pays
occidentaux se sont refroidies et les
pourparlers sur l'accord de vienne sont
à l'arrêt il n'y a pas moyen de
contourner l'accord si vous voulez être
un pays respecté dans la communauté
internationale il n'y a pas moyen de le
contourner nous devons travailler
ensemble depuis la sortie des états unis
des accords de vienne en 2018 sous la
présidence de donald trump téhéran a
augmenté ses capacités de production
d'uranium enrichi l'iran se rapproche
des 90% nécessaire à la fabrication
d'une bombe alors que les accords fixer
la limite à 3 bien que 67% une
transgression inquiétante pour la
communauté internationale mais également
pour israël le voisin et ennemi juré de
l'iran dans la région
et elle a une également ce soir cet
entretien entre le président russe et
son homologue chinois à l'occasion pour
vladimir poutine ex jean ping de revenir
sur le succès de relations bilatérales
un échange par visio conférence pour
parler également la présence russe jeux
olympiques d'hiver de pékin mais il est
extrait
l'importance des relations bilatérales
entre moscou et pékin lors de leur
rencontre les deux chefs d'état ont mis
l'accent sur cet aspect majeur fait du
marketing s'est félicité de l'état de
ses relations ainsi que des échanges
commerciaux entre les deux pays qui ont
atteint 123 milliards de dollars sur la
période de janvier à novembre il a en
outre mis en exergue la coopération
russo-chinoise dans la lutte contre la
pandémie de corona viance les deux pays
ont mis en place ce nouveau modèle de
coopération qui se base sur les sujets
comme la non ingérence aux affaires
internes aussi bien que le respect
mutuel des deux parties et nous avons
décidé de transformer est les frontières
en
ceinture de l'amitié qui ne permet de
renforcer les relations commerciales et
le chiffre d'affaires a augmenté de 31
pour cent jusqu'à 120 3 milliards de
dollars ce qui nous a permis de dire on
nous avons
dépassé le record avant les pandémies
par rapport à 2010 9è et comme nous
sommes convenus nous allons dépasser
bientôt
le niveau 2 200 milliards de dollars et
nous sommes en train de réaliser des
projets d'envergure dans l'agriculture
et dans le domaine de haute technologie
et dès le début de la pandémie nous
avons réuni nos efforts visant à abattre
l'infection à cornavin russell et la
chine devient le centre international de
production des vaccins russey spoutnik
mai et spots nick knight nous avons
signé les contrats qui permet de
produire plus de 150 millions de doses à
part les efforts de six fabricants
chinois xi jinping à lui remercié son
homologue russe de s'être opposé aux
tentatives extérieure visant à semer la
discorde entre moscou et pékin d'après
le chef d'état chinois les relations
entre les deux pays ont prouvé leur
résilience vous je tenais les efforts de
la chine pour protéger ses intérêts
nationaux clé vous avez été opposés à
des tentatives de
créer des problèmes entre nos deux pays
je j'ai apprécié notre relation je suis
prêt à faire le bilan de cette année
a dressé la liste de nos projets pour
renforcer notre coopération dans divers
domaines
pour les intérêts d'une coopération
durable que très haute qualité dans nos
relations nous voyons qu'il ya des
processus
internationaux et de la pandémie qui
sont très intéressants seront
interconnectés le monde a commencé cette
ère de la turbulence notre coopération
russo chinoise a surmonté des épreuves
s'est montrée vita si jean ping a
également insisté sur le lien fort entre
la russie et la chine en matière de
coopération sportive y compris en
refusant de politiser le sport
casimir poutine a confirmé sa visite en
chine en février à l'occasion des jeux
olympiques de pékin en entretien d'une
heure et demie bien remplie donc entre
des amis et des états pour reprendre les
termes du premier coup de projecteur à
présent sur une question pourquoi
l'arctique est devenue une région
stratégique aussi convoité un territoire
pourtant aux conditions extrêmes et
bouleversé par le réchauffement
climatique dernier pays en date à
s'intéresser à l'article au royaume uni
les précisions d'antoine claireaux
les autorités britanniques
s'enorgueillissent de locus cette
alliance tripartite entre londres
canberra et washington en région du
pacifique qui a rappelons le fait
capoter la vente de sous-marins français
à l'australie pour une somme dépassant
les 50 milliards d'euros tant et si bien
que londres se verraient bien adapté ce
modèle à d'autres régions du monde comme
l'arctique en unissant nos forces et
celles des états unis et de l'australie
nous protégeons les routes maritimes et
la stabilité à travers l'inde au
pacifique nous approfondissons notre
travail au canada pour couvrir des
régions comme l'arctique et au delà
cette sortie s'inscrit en réalité dans
une tendance qui voit se rapprocher de
plus en plus londres et ottawa sur la
question arctique car un autre accord de
formation cette fois ci entre les forces
militaires canadiennes et britanniques a
été signé en octobre 2021 et devrait
voir des membres de la royal navy
s'entraîner à bord des brise glaces des
garde-côtes canadiens un rapprochement
entre autres militaires entre le canada
et le royaume-uni que n'a pas manqué de
souligner l'ambassade de russie à
londres
les forces armées britanniques qui
avance agressivement vers nos frontières
en pologne et en estonie et les
responsables militaires britanniques
déclarent ouvertement leur intention
d'établir une sorte de présence
militaire dans l'arctique
moscou de son côté a depuis des années
et renforcer sa présence en arctique en
développant les infrastructures et en
rouvrant des bases militaires parmi les
huit pays riverains de l'océan glacial
la russie est probablement le pays qui
mise le plus sur le développement de la
région de quoi susciter quelques
curiosités et de fait sur le terrain on
y constate une présence accrue de
navires et aéronefs de pays de l'otan
les forces navales des états unis et des
pays de l'otan continuent de mener
régulièrement des campagnes individuels
et groupes et deux navires de guerre de
surface en mer de barents nous
constatons une augmentation de la durée
de présence des sous marins et navires
de surface de l' us navy en mer de
barents et de norvège
depuis le mois de mai la russie assure
la présidence tournante du conseil de
l'arctique l'opportunité pour elle de
promouvoir ses intérêts dans la région
mais aussi d'appeler à la coopération
entre pays membres les spectateurs
si quelqu'un veut plus de prévisibilité
et souhaite réduire les risques sur le
plan militaire dans l'arctique je
propose de revenir à notre proposition
de longue date de réintroduire la
pratique des réunions régulières entre
chefs d'état major des forces armées des
pays membres du conseil de l'arctique
l'implication militaire lactique de
toujours plus d'acteurs sans lien
particulier avec la région est déjà une
réalité et cette tendance n'a pas
vocation à apaiser la situation bien au
contraire
c'est avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons la lutte contre le coc
vie 19 et ces variants un nouveau
conseil de défense sanitaire aura lieu
vendredi en france pour évoquer
d'éventuelles restrictions
supplémentaires face à la flambée des
cas dans le même temps la vaccination
des 5 11 ans a débuté aujourd'hui dans
plusieurs pays d'europe alors 2022 sort
at-elle mieux du point de vue du coc
vide c'est la question on vous pose ce
soir sur tegra vie
[Musique]
cette semaine on va passer en revue
l'actualité économique une bonne partie
des économistes qui pensent que tout ce
qui a été fait a été bien fait que
structurellement l'économie va bien que
le chômage a vraiment été vaincue que le
pib a augmenté moi je vois pas où sont
les fondamentaux qui sont bon bah non
justement le problème c'est que la
bourse elles montrent simplement parce
que les banques centrales injectent de
l'argent le monde entier sous perfusion
là on a un vrai problème on ne sait pas
comment débrancher la perfusion quand
vous déversez comme ça et que vous
endetter pour faire 5 10 % de déficit
budgétaire
évidemment vous avez un résidu qui
arrive en pipe et heureusement faut
arrêter de prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles et leur annoncer à chaque fois
que demain l'herbe est plus verte parce
que demain malheureusement l'herbe elle
est moche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres c'est le silence qui parle
[Musique]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française elle est aussi critiquée ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si mort
au maintien de l'ordre et une
catastrophe est tout à fait déplorable
on a vu des personnes gravement blessées
on a entendu aussi le terme violences
policières ce débat sur les violences
policières à ce qu'il a toujours existé
il a toujours existé ou la première
grande manifestation parisienne du 6
février 34 noeuds même pu craindre la
disparition de la toute jeune garde
républicaine mobile tant la presse
s'était déchaînée sur ce qui était
réellement le noyau dur du dispositif de
maintien d'ordre à l'époque
[Musique]
l'afrique australe a n'est pas la seule
région touchée on peut c'est également
l'afrique de l'ouest comment la
situation pourrait évoluer le nombre
d'hospitalisations n'a pas également
augmenté unia que 6% des nids à
réanimation qui sont actuellement
occupés cette évolution les vania qui
apparaissent là sont des évolutions
naturelles de mutation de virus est ce
que les pays du nord les pays les plus
avancés en matière de couverture
vaccinale doivent freiner justement le
processus d dose de rappel anglais en
fait on est pas su protéger personne
n'est protégé des vues du site ne
connaissent pas de frontières il nous
faut continuer à lutter contre la
commune dans son entièreté pour pouvoir
éviter que ce type dont deux phénomènes
en avait beaucoup plus fréquemment
[Musique]
un des freins à priori du nucléaire
c'est l'émergence dé nouvelles sources
d'énergie aujourd'hui nous sommes le
pays qui produit l'électricité la pluie
décarbonés au monde on peut rêver à
couvrir toute la planète de d'éoliennes
mais quand ça produit un tiers du temps
que fait-on pour le res d'appui il ya
aussi la démographie en sont toujours à
l'afrique quand même avec un milliard
d'habitants en plus la surface de
l'afrique ne sera pas suffisante pour
mettre des panneaux solaires ou sinon ça
se fera au détriment de l'agriculture on
joue aux apprentis sorciers y compris au
niveau européen quand un pays comme
l'allemagne décide du lourd lama
d'arrêter le nucléaire trouvera les
centrales à charbon l'allemagne est le
plus gros pollueurs européens
aujourd'hui le gia qui a sonné l'alarmé
sur les risques de l'ue réchauffement
climatique dit bien que les besoins en
électricité sont considérables d'ici
2050 il faudra 50 % de production
électrique en plus comment va-t-on faire
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions des procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux et d'aidé
de jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez
pas comment votre fils est mort vous
devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter ils étaient ni sur la liste
des morts nés sur l'île d'eubée
scénariste et hopitalisé il était nulle
part est ce qu'on peut vivre malgré
cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à la fois
je souffrais parce que ça me rappelait
des beaux souvenirs avec stéphane en
même temps c'était très douloureux et
puis aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que
ça permettait d'extraire de de moi même
toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire la lutte contre le communisme
et ces variants un nouveau conseil de
défense sanitaire aura lieu vendredi en
france pour évoquer d'éventuelles
restrictions supplémentaires face à la
flambée des cas la vaccination des 5 11
ans ouverte à partir d'aujourd'hui pour
les enfants à risque et depuis ce matin
les français de plus de 65 ans et ont
reçu une deuxième dose doivent faire
leur rappelle pour conserver leur pass
thani terre
et alors la campagne de vaccination
était d'argile agence européenne des
maladies affirme pourtant aujourd'hui
que le vaccin ne suffira pas pour
contrer la propagation du variant
omicron elle appelle à prendre toutes
les mesures et appelle à la prudence
accrue en cette période de fêtes mais
jusqu'où peuvent aller ces restrictions
qui prennent déjà à la gorge de nombreux
professionnels dans notre rubrique qu'en
pensent les français nous irons à la
rencontre d'un traiteur en région
parisienne qui aujourd'hui craint de
devoir fermer boutique définitivement
et c'est reparti donc pour un énième
conseil de défense sanitaire ce sera
vendredi prochain le gouvernement
pourrait annoncer de nouvelles mesures
de lutte contre l' qu'ovide et pour
tenter d'enrayer l'explosion des cas et
la poussée de mikron la campagne de
vaccination s'accélère aussi on retrouve
notre reporter estelle farges devant le
ministère de la santé bon poids reste
elle s'est donc le coup d'envoi de la
vaccination des 5 11 ans les plus
fragiles
exactement stéphanie et les enfants qui
présentent au moins une comorbidité ou
alors ceux qui vivent avec une personnes
immunodéprimées peuvent se faire
vacciner dès aujourd'hui il s'agit d'une
version pédiatrique du vaccin files
heures bio ntech 360 mille enfants sont
concernés puis dans les semaines qui
viennent en fonction de ce que dira la
haute autorité de santé la vaccination
des 5 11 ans pourrait être élargie à
tous les enfants sur la base du
volontariat
estelle autre échéance aujourd'hui aussi
qui concerne cette fois les plus de 65
ans
[Musique]
oui stéphanie aujourd'hui était la dette
elle limite ce pour la dose de rappel
est destiné aux plus de 65 ans du moins
ceux dont la dernière injection a été
fait il y avait sept mois ce qui n'ont
pas effectué cette dose de rappel et
bien elles risquent de perdre leur pass
sanitaire selon les données de la
direction générale de la santé quatre
cent mille personnes pourraient perdre
se passe sanitaire des mesures donc être
décidées il y a quelques semaines pour
tenter de freiner les contaminations
avec l'arrivée un du variant omicron qui
il faut le dire n'arrange rien l' agence
européenne est des maladies elle d'ores
et déjà averti la vaccination seule ne
suffira pas elle réclame d une action en
forte et urgente pour limiter l'impact
de ce variantes en france vous l'avez
dit un nouveau conseil de défense se
tiendra vendredi merci estelle farge et
une campagne de vaccination qui
s'accélère donc mais qui pourrait être
insuffisant pour contrer la propagation
du nouveau barioz omicron des
restrictions supplémentaires sont sur la
table donc une réflexion qui inquiète
certains professionnels à la poule
défaite dans notre rubrique qu'en
pensent les français ce soir nous allons
justement à la rencontre de guillaume
patron d'une entreprise de traiteur il
vit avec la peur au ventre depuis la
crise sanitaire en cas de mesures plus
strictes il pourrait bel et bien mettre
la clé sous la porte un reportage signé
nadège abderrazak essayant maginel
nous sommes à gennevilliers pour y
retrouver guillaume goubert cas il est
gérant d'une entreprise de traiteur
bonjour et guillaume vous affronter
cette cinquième bague de kovy de 19 avec
beaucoup de craintes et d'appréhension
et pour cause elle pourrait vous coûter
votre entreprise expliquez nous pourquoi
et bien parce qu'effectivement on a un
gros souci d'annulation d'événements de
réception de voeux des maires de fin
d'année d'entreprise à cause du nom
regroupements et les gens ont peur de se
regrouper afin de de se retrouver et de
fêter cette fin d'année tout simplement
et depuis depuis quinze jours on est
soumis à de très grosses annulations sur
des événements de 20 à 3000 personnes
tout simplement et ça devient très
préoccupant aussi bien sur le sur le
public que sur le privé maintenant
combien vous évaluer les pertes
financières au boeuf un peu près entre
80 et 82 mille euros
sur le mois de décembre sur le mois de
décembre oui on s'est débrouillé s'est
démené pour essayer de trouver des
vaccins mais c'est pas des vaccins qui
vous empêche de l'avoir cédé vaccin qui
vous empêchent les formes graves il faut
attendre d'avoir certainement ce vaccin
qui nous permettra de recommencer à nous
retrouver mais nous pendant ce temps là
on a besoin d'être aidé au prorata de ce
qu'on perd cirque on peut justifier nos
événements d'annuler on les justifie
vous n'êtes pas suffisamment aidé c'est
ça que vous me dites on est pas on n'est
pas suffisamment entendue vous avez
écrit à emmanuel macron vous directement
j'ai écrit oui c'était l'année dernière
quand on était à la deuxième vague est
ce que vous lui avez dit je vais
demander de l'aide
en fait ça résume un peu tout j'ai dit
que je voulais pas que ma société elle
ferme c'est une société de famille et
j'y tiens et je lâcherai pas donc thiam
ont donné effectivement c'est avec
beaucoup d'émotion je vous parle je veux
pas lâcher donc je veux juste qu'on
m'écoute juste qu'on laisse travailler
est ce que le président de la république
vous a répondu son ministère oui par les
produits comme quoi effectivement ma
demande avait été entendu que j'aurai
une réponse dans les plus brefs délais
où que ce soit effectivement il y aurait
une annonce par décret interdisant le
nom au groupement et c'est ce qui s'est
passé mais du 1er septembre au 31
septembre on était perdus et et en
octobre qu'on a interdit le regroupement
par décret est là aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'on demande est ce qu'on est en droit
de se regrouper ou pas vous avez pu
bénéficier de ce pge ce fameux prêts
garantis par l'état y vous a aidé comme
il le fallait oui m'a aidé il m'a aidé
beaucoup parce que ça m'a permis d'être
un peu plus serein sur l'évolution du
métier et comment me retourner face à la
crise le souci c'est que c'en est fini
de ce fait je maintenant c'est l'année
où il va falloir le rembourser le
problème c'est que si vous ne travaillez
pas ça va être compliqué ça va être très
compliqué on a eu la possibilité de le
repousser un an l'état nous a permis
cela je les fais parce que je ne savais
pas où j'allais et même s'il ya un
engouement à partir de septembre sur mon
métier où les gens ont voulu se réunir
et c'est là ça recommence à être une
situation vraiment très très
préoccupante et je pèse mes mots dans
l'incertitude la plus complète sujet de
votre avenir totalement totalement que
ce soit décembre ou janvier totalement
c'est pas des reports c'est des
annulations simplement c'est resté
plusieurs mois sans son salaire
six mois en fait un sans salaire donc on
mange ses économies comme comme toute
personne normalement constituée quoi et
un loyer à payer j'ai des frais j'ai des
petits jets voilà et je lâche pas comme
ça il ya un monde et ça fait 18 ans que
je fais ce métier non je tant que
j'aurai pas tout essayé
je lâcherai pas je vous vois voilà j'ai
une conscience professionnelle
je veux je me dire à moi même j'ai tout
essayé on est en pleine campagne
électorale
avec des candidats qui sont plus à
l'écouté en tout cas que et que
d'habitude si vous aviez un message à
leur dire ce serait quoi
d'être plus proche plus souvent de la
rue
des petites entreprises pas forcément
des grosses qui elle aussi méritent
d'être écoutés parce qu'elles brassent
soit beaucoup de personnel ou beaucoup
d'enjeux qu'ils soient économiques ou
humain mais il ya un moment donné faut
écouter aussi
les légendes qui travaillent tous les
jours dans des dans n'importe quel
métier et les politiques qu'ils soient
maires députés sénateurs que celle on en
a besoin mais il ya un monde les fois
qu'ils écoutent un peu plus dans l'année
tous les gens
alors un an après le début de la
vaccination massive pas mal de
découragement on viens de l'entendre un
chai ce traiteur et chez pas mal de
français il faut bien de reconnaître
certaines professions sont meurtris sur
le plan sanitaire le moral n'est pas au
rendez-vous à dix jours de noël la
vaccination ne suffira pas dit ce soir
l'agencé européenne des maladies de quoi
se poser des questions alors va-t-on
enfin voir le bout du tunnel est ce que
2022 sera mieux on attend toujours vos
réactions sur le comté d g berthet
france et place à notre décryptage
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler bruno
m'égare ban chef du service réanimation
à l'hôpital lariboisière à paris bon
soit on veut nommer garden merci d'être
avec nous à vos côté joëlle mélin
députée européenne est reine bonsoir
madame merci d'être avec nous
france-côte rubber délégué départemental
du modem merci à vous également le mini
de la santé donc un qui évoque cet après
midi à leur semblait une vague longa qui
frappe tout le pays sans distinction
avec un taux d'incidence est levée et le
porte-parole gabriel attal qui met en
garde écouter la pression va continuer à
s'accentuer durant les prochaines
semaines et nous devrions dépasser les
3000 patients atteints du coc vide en
réanimation très rapidement et atteindre
les 4000 patients atteints du cosy
denrées animations autour des fêtes
alors c'est pas très brillant 4000
patients en réagir rappelle que c'est à
5000 un conte avait expliqué que le
système hospitalier craquer qu'il
fallait confiné aujourd'hui bruno meier
banon n'ait quasiment tous vaccinés
c'est quand même un petit peu la douche
froide qu'est-ce qui se passe
écoutez comme vous le savez il y à peu
près 6 millions de français non
vaccinées dont 1 1 million de personnes
âgées avec des comorbidités
malheureusement le virus donc le variant
d'état circulent à un niveau extrêmement
élevé donc le risque d'être contaminé
est important et malheureusement ces
personnes on prenne un risque en étant
contaminée de développer une forme grave
de la maladie et donc de devoir être
hospitalisée y compris d'aller en
réanimation y compris malheureusement
de décéder malgré tout les traitements
qu'on peut offrir à l'hôpital me fait
évidemment la vaccination on le sait
aujourd'hui
protège parfaitement contre le risque de
faire une forme grave de la maladie et
donc évidemment où je renouvelle l'appel
que les autorités sanitaires ont déjà
lancé à la vaccination de tous les
adultes et bien sûr surtout les
personnes à haut risque de faire une
pomme grappes sachant évidemment que à
partir de la vaccination il faut
attendre un mois et demi pour avoir là
protection nécessaire
or le problème c'est que ces personnes
qui
malheureusement parce qu'elles ont reçu
une mauvaise information ne croyant pas
à l'intérêt de la vaccination
adoptent le mode de vie des personnes
vaccinées et donc de fait évidemment
sont contaminés et se retrouve dans
l'animation aujourd'hui 80% des
personnes en réanimation ne sont pas
vaccinés alors sauf que les choses ne
semblent pas vraiment s'arranger le
nouveau variant mikron pourrait devenir
dominants d'ici à mi-février alerte
lancée aujourd'hui par la présidente de
la commission européenne alors quand
dans le même temps l'agencé européenne
prévient que la vaccination seule ne
suffira pas joël mêlant il ya de quoi
être un peu pessimiste et avoir le moral
dans les chaussettes m
oui même sans ces informations on l'a
automatiquement
le fait est qu'il faut reconnaître que
il ya de quoi être déboussolé
surtout si on s'aperçoit que pour la
deuxième année consécutive et si on se
retourne vers les chinois ça fait plus
de deux ans et demi que ce virus hini
siens que le virus initial circulent et
que l'on peut se dire à quoi sert la
vaccination alors moi je serais un petit
peu et auteur j'ai été pour la
vaccination initialement donc j'ai suivi
toutes les consignes à lui pour ma
famille proche et moi même au temps
effectivement de se poser un problème
parce qu'on n'est pas dans une véritable
politique vaccinale on est d'abord avec
des thérapies géniques qu'on ne
connaissait pas encore il ya un an au
moins dans leur application et 2 nous
savons très bien que nous vaccinons à
partir d'une souche qui a dix femmes
lévy dablement initiale a disparu depuis
au moins 18 mois d'ailleurs le
renouvellement au niveau de l'europe les
mains à renouveler certains contrats
avec les laboratoires que dans la mesure
où il nous proposons des souches adapté
or la politique vaccinale veut que l'umq
que l'on vaccine avec des souches qui
ont été pré déterminée de nombreux mois
avant qu'on ait du temps sur la chaîne
de production l'orgue du tout il est
évident que ça marche de moins en moins
bien donc c'est assez déboussolant comme
tout le monde et aussi il ya des tonnes
mesure gestion pas prise la première
c'est bien entendu ne pas prendre de
mesures rapport aux zones d'arrivée du
vaccin c'est à dire venant des stands
ouest c'est classique mais aussi pour la
troisième fois d'angleterre et de
manière massive on ne prend aucune
mesure de protection aux frontières je
dis pas les fermer c'est à dire les
mesures ordinaire aucune mesure de
monsieur bergame et germann on en avait
déjà parlé des mesures d'isolement
automatique des cas avérés en hôtel
qu'ovide il faudra qu'on y arrive mieux
vaut même si ces cinquante mille
personnes par jour mieux vaut isolé
50000 c'est à dire à peu près de cent
mille deux cent cinquante mille
personnes par semaine que tout un pays
enfin je veux dire ça tombe sous le sens
et personne ne l'a fait on a parlé de
séquençage et enfin on n'a absolument
pas travailler sur les thérapeutiques
alternatives il faudra qu elle aussi on
en parlera justement joël maintenant
parce qu'il ya les airs quel sort est
une pilule d'ailleurs qu'il sort
aujourd'hui euros aux états unis mais
restons justement sur ce bariolés sur
cette vaccination
on va voir ce chiffre un cas communiqué
les laboratoires pfizer by one tech 1 le
vaccin donc vous lisiez moins efficace
contre le vario mikron il protège 15 70%
contre les casses les verts vous allez
me dire que c'est déjà pas mal mais
enfin quand même ça baisse de 20%
clairement france au 4e boeuf pourquoi
on n'attend pas que pfizer sorte une
version modifiée en mars je crois prévue
pour mars pour faire cette fameuse
troisième dose à laquelle tout le monde
nous exhorte c'est vrai que
j'en ai comprennent plus rien
et je crois qu'on n'attend pas parce que
nous sommes à la mi décembre et que si
nous attendons le mois de mars d'avoir
un vaccin qui soit pleinement
opérationnelle à supposer qu'ils le soir
il y aura eu quelques milliers quelques
dizaines de milliers de morts d'ici là
donc je le gouvernement par plus traiter
et nous apprenions tout à l'heure se
traite est tellement émouvant
évidemment qu'il voudrait des consignes
claires qu'il voudrait de l'anticipation
qu'il voudrait des mesures générales
mais il n'est pas possible de mettre
tout un pays sous cloche nous le savons
bien il n'y a pas dans notre pays des
obligations vaccinales
donc il faut tenir avec les moyens du
bord et s'adapter au jour le jour je
pense que c'est ce que fait le
gouvernement
j'espère qu'ils auront à être efficace
dans quelques mois j'espère et je pense
que les vaccins s'adapteront mais il
faut aussi en appeler à la
responsabilité de chacun c'est à dire
qu'on soit d'ailleurs vacciner ou pas
s'abstenir d'un exter de fréquentation
sociale d'un excès de fait d'un excès de
peau de fin d'année contre diverses
respecter les gestes barrières et il n'y
a que par la responsabilité individuelle
on arrivera à tenir le temps qu'il
faudra ça commence à faire beaucoup des
restrictions beaucoup de sacrifices à
nous tous on va aussi prendre l'exemple
d'un octogénaire aujourd'hui en février
dernier cette personne était convoqué
pour cette première dose suivi de la
deuxième 15 jours après six mois plus
tard juillet dernier donc rappelle avec
la troisième dose en janvier cette
personne aura un rappel pour une
nouvelle dose ça fera donc si j'ai bien
compté en une année quatre doses
bruno m'égare ban quand même ça remet
pas un petit peu en question
l'efficacité des vaccins quand on sait
en plus qu'on va avoir une nouvelle
version en mars et un nouveau variant
avec l'efficacité qu'on connaît
alors tout d'abord juste mais je me
permets de faire une petite correction
de ce que je viens d'entendre donc le
vaccin actuellement à base d'arn
messager n'est pas du tout une thérapie
génique ça n'est pas du tout un vaccin
expérimental c'est un vaccin qui a suivi
toutes les démarches nécessaires pour
obtenir l'autorisation sur le marché est
aujourd'hui plus de 7 milliards
d'individus sur la planète ont reçu
cette vaccination
donc jamais un médicament n'a bénéficié
d'autant de personnes sur un court un
temps aussi court pour pouvoir en
déterminer et l'efficacité et les effets
secondaires potentiels alors je suis
d'accord effectivement il peut y avoir
nécessité d'adapter le vaccin mais comme
vous le savez ceux ci prend au minimum
une centaine de jours or entre autant
aujourd'hui notamment nous faisons face
à un variant delta et malheureusement il
y à une baisse de la protection conférée
par la double dose donc attendre une
possible adaptation du
delà de la dose de rappel aux variants
omicron il devrait arriver dans les
semaines qui viennent serait totalement
on va dire
malheureusement est erronée car ça
permettrait d'exposer la personne à un
risque important de faire une forme
grave lié au delta et de se retrouver à
l'hôpital ou en réanimation il sera
toujours temps si nécessaire par la
suite de recevoir une dose adapté mais
pour le moment la dose de rappel permet
de booster l'immunité d'obtenir une
protection parfaite contre la souche qui
circulent quasiment à 100% aujourd'hui
sur le territoire national et donc c'est
ce qu'il faut faire il faut suivre les
recommandations des autorités sanitaires
on verra par la suite ce que ce qu'il en
sera pour le variante omicron
aujourd'hui à nouveau on ne sait même
pas quelle en est sa virulence on sait à
peu près que la triple vaccination
devrait conférer un certain niveau de
protection certes diminué mais néanmoins
70% de protection ça reste une
protection parfaitement acceptable même
les vaccins contre la grippe ne ne
confère pas une telle protection
aujourd'hui alors sauf quand ça met pas
en confiance tout le monde en 1978
regardez ce message telegraph qui nous
parvient on aimerait en voir la fin de
ce qu'on vide car la multiplication des
doses de rappel ne met pas en confiance
c'était à la question suivante est-ce
que 2022 ce sera mieux donc sept
personnes qui ne se sont pas vraiment en
confiance avec toutes ces dose de rappel
jouer le mélange justement je rebondis
sur ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
ses traitements alternatifs la fase
heures sur une pilule qui sort aux
etats-unis aujourd'hui
efficace à 90% contre les formes graves
pourquoi ne pas attendre que cette
pilule soit produite en masse à ce que
en tout cas ça c'est la question que
beaucoup se posent vous votre avis
eh bien écoutez cette ville j'ai suivi
comme tout le monde que se réactive sur
les langues rares mais le problème est
plutôt de
se demander pourquoi depuis le 1er
janvier 2020 cela va faire deux au
défaut européens et des fonds nationaux
en europe ont été développés pour
pouvoir évaluer des molécules inconnu
certes mais aussi des molécules connues
et qu' il ya eu de nombreux laboratoires
d'université qui ont ils des sommes très
importantes pour aller évaluer et on le
sait d'ailleurs souvent ce sont des
anciennes molécules à peine modifiée qui
peuvent servir il y a bien entendu la
prévention à tour des médicaments pour
la prévention attendre les médicaments
pour la
base de contacts est-ce qu'on a des
médicaments pour l'homme le moment où on
est positif mais à symptomatique ou peu
symptomatiques et il semblerait des
possibilités sur les formes plus graves
dès l'instant qu'on est en milieu
hospitalier ou voir même plus il y avait
probablement alors ça a été le débat on
en sait bien sûr l'accord qui nie les
lectines fait break toll tous ces
produits qu'on a évoqué il n'est pas
sortie d'études on n'a pas permis qu'ils
sortaient des cumuls importants c'est ça
qui est tout à fait de marche il y a eu
des études européenne qui n'ont pas
abouti laissons rien dire et qui re dire
très clairement aux scientifiques dans
des cadres habituels d'expérimentation
que ça ne marche pas qu'on leur laisse
pas croire qu'on peut faire marcher en
attendant on aurait l'île depuis deux
ans avoir des molécules alternatif sur
le marché j'entends bien que c'est
toujours long mais pour ce qui est comme
disait monsieur ben guerdane pour les
rênes mais sachez qu'on connaissait
depuis très longtemps et c'est pas le
problème c'est pas une expérimentation
de sorte que les uns et les autres
pandémies non ont été apportés donc on
n'a pas eu le mal utilisé il y à une
nécessité mais sur le marché des
molécules qui doivent exister ou qui
doivent être déjà en phase iii que l'on
doit pouvoir mettre sur le marché c'est
une attente urgent bien évidemment fin
de croître à baffes à 107 propositions
vous vous partagez cette demande et
cette urgence un de nombreux français
tout de même pas
écouté que vous dire vous savez c'est un
cessez le bilan coût avantage cheyrou
juriste c'est à dire que évidemment il
ya des risques à se faire vacciner mais
il y en a sans doute moins que de ne pas
être vaccinés et et voilà il faut parer
au plus pressé et un jour le traitement
arrivera et puis aussi on sait que toute
pandémie fini par s'arrêter la grippe
espagnole s'est arrêtée tout seul
mais ce qu'il faut c'est de tenir
jusqu'à ce que cela s'arrête en ayant le
moins de morts possibles donc parant au
plus pressé et puis individuellement
soyons responsables de votre
comportement personnel et manama cran
l'instant qui nous dit qu il est
probable encore qu'on aille justement
inverse des rappels régulier ça va pas
vraiment arrangé beaucoup de monde
certainement l'hypothèse d'une
obligation vaccinale et existe dit
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron bruno
m'égare ban mais le président qui évoque
aussi la vaccination des 11 5 ans il dit
que c'est souhaitable mais que ça sera
laissée à la discrétion des parents
votre réaction justement dans l'à
beaucoup débattu ensemble évidemment
l'hypothèse d'une obligation vaccinale
existe ça veut dire ça y est on prépare
clairement le terrain et et c'est
souhaitable selon le médecin en tout cas
que vous êtes
alors comme vous l'avez dit les
coronavirus sont des virus à l'origine
d'infections peu immunisante il était
donc attendu qu'il serait difficile de
mettre au point un vaccin qui
conférerait une immunité prolonger deux
fait effectivement on s'attendait à voir
des rappels avec une certaine fréquence
que l'on va découvrir au fur et à mesure
bien sûr du temps et de l'arrivée de
variants nouveau cela ne me choque pas
il ya beaucoup d'autres vaccinations
pour lequel il ya plusieurs dose de
rappel à faire ne serait-ce que le
tétanos et inédits n'ont donc travaux de
contrôle
il n'est pas encore dit qu'il faille
faire des rappels tous les six mois le
tétanos ou fait la vaccination à la
naissance puis en appel à six mois puis
un an puis à 5 ans puis tous les dix ans
voyez donc c'est quelque chose
d'habituel
s'est pas non c'est pas tous les six
mois on verra on verra personne
aujourd'hui ne peut dire que c'est un
sujet c'est un déficit immunitaire qu'il
faille faire une dose de rappel dans six
mois on ne sait pas par contre très
probablement il faudra adapter le vaccin
à dose de rappel à venir aux souches
prédominante qui vont arriver et avec le
temps il faut rester confiant des
vaccins plus puissants
induisant une immunité plus solides
seront développés donc pour revenir au
sujet de la vaccination des enfants
comme vous le savez je suis plutôt
favorable bien sûr sans obligation mais
il n'y a aucune
on de maintenir dans la population un
groupe de personnes non vaccinées qui
d'abord s'exposerait un risque malgré
tout de formes graves de la maladie il
faut rappeler qu'il ya quinzaine
d'enfants décédés en france le coït 19
et environ 5000 hospitalisé y compris en
réanimation donc ou disposent d'un moyen
parfaitement efficace pour réduire la
morbi mortalité y compris chez les
enfants il faut leur faire profiter sans
compter évidemment que le fait de
réduire la circulation du virus dans la
population
réduire le risque
d'exposer des personnes plus âgées nées
à risque de faire des formes graves de
la maladie tant à la vaccination
obligatoire je pense malheureusement
elle sera compliqué à mettre dans des
faits est donc très clairement elle
deviendra obligatoire lorsque l'on aura
trouvé et démontrer la vaccination des
nouveau-nés sera sans danger à smolensk
en général merci en tout cas à tous les
trois françois cattoire bof joëlle mélin
et bruno megaman d'avoir été avec nous
et c'est la fin de cette émission rendez
vous dès demain 20 heures d'ici là
n'oubliez pas de réagir sur notre compte
télégramme verte et france l'actualité
continue
[Musique]
la situation politique d'abord c'est
quoi votre analyse de cette espèce de
tsunami
les choses commencent à s'organiser plus
entre deux poules ou trois peut-être la
france elle est entre la droite et
l'extrême droite on peut pas éviter ce
constat la situation politique va se
passer à droite et sur des thématiques
de droite ça veut dire par exemple que
votre candidate est obligé de durcir ses
positions de droite l'idée de ces
primaires internes c'était de créer à
l'arrivée une équipe de france et
l'équipe de france elle est là c'est la
première fois première fois dans
l'histoire de france qu'une femme selon
les sondages peut être élue présidente
de la république c'est sans doute une
révolution qui permet de dire que le
plafond de verre a peut être enfin
exploser
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui ai des gants dit il
n'y a pas d'alternative au sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pj les jeunes
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
il ya cette dérive lui classiques basés
sur l'ésotérisme et il ya un autre
terrain de jeu pour les gourous qu'on a
découvert notamment avec la crise
sanitaire 1 c'est internet on est moins
ceux des jo de mystique moins religieuse
comme on peut vous pouvez la voir et
reste en 10 80 que sur des phénomènes
qui vont concerner la santé ou
l'alimentation et la crise du coc vide à
renforcer cette nouvelle porte d'entrée
dans les dérives sectaires ou des
groupes ont plutôt parlé de vaccination
plutôt parler d'alimentation plutôt
parler de guérison au lieu d'aller
directement sur un terrain qui sera un
terrain religieux ou mystique on
retrouve par exemple dans les dernières
manifestations anti vaccin contre le coc
vides certains éléments qui se
rattachent à des mouvements à tendance
sectaire qui historiquement sont opposés
à toute vaccination
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ces dossiers sensibles je vais
partager avec vous mon interprétation
depuis plus d'un an le président macron
à préparer ses premiers mois de
présidence européenne
en comptant l'utiliser sur tous les
plans pour contribuer à sa réélection
ils étaient convaincus que leurs autres
annonces la chancelière allemande le
positionnerait comme le chef naturel
d'une europe à laquelle il imposerait
ses vues et je suis lui permettre et et
montrer aux français que grâce à lui
l'avenir de leur pays passer dorénavant
par l'union européenne ce qui
correspondait à la fois à ses
convictions comme un nostalgique de
grandeur qui caractérise nombre de nos
concitoyens
la réalité allemande est venue frapper
ce plan de plein fouet en faisant
apparaître de nombreuses divergences qui
vend tout compliquer à la surprise
générale c'est olaf scholz ministre des
finances et chef du parti
social-démocrate située à gauche qui a
gagné les élections contre les verts et
la cdu donné favori en moins de deux
mois soit moitié moins que celui dont
avait eu besoin la chancelière en 2017
il a ensuite construit un accord de
gouvernement tricolore avec les verts et
les libéraux et en définitive on voit
que cette coalition progressiste veut
changer l'allemagne en profondeur en
quatre ans le programme commun qu'il
s'apprête à mettre en oeuvre vise à
conforter clairement le leadership
européen de l'allemagne grandes
puissances économiques qui